what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with the really the finale of
the century by Paul Jenkins and Jay Lee
and this is of course where the Grand
Puba fight happens with a century and
like everybody else right one of the
coolest moments in the entirety of
Marvel Comics so the first thing to
understand here is coming out of the
last video that we did which you'll find
a link to it down in the description
that we ended up having this Revelation
that Robert Reynolds where we thought he
was a schizophrenic struggling with
mental illness and coping with
alcoholism that he is actually a
superhero and for whatever reason nobody
remembers that he exists nobody
remembers that he's even the century at
all and so in an effort to understand
why this is going on what Robert
Reynolds is doing over the course of
this video going into his conclusion is
that he's literally traveling around
visiting some of the most prominent
superheroes that he was actually friends
with and trying to understand why nobody
recalls his existence the first person
he visits is Reed Richards of the
Fantastic Four now there's a few reasons
why this is the case the first is
because according to Robert Reynolds as
he's talking to Reed both he and Reed
were best friends at one point in time
and two because the Fantastic Four or
kind of like the the grandfather right
just the original superheroes in Marvel
Comics right the most respected
superhero team out there and so it makes
sense that he would go to read first but
the first question that Reed has when
Robert Reynolds arrives on the scene is
how in the world did you get in here
right I mean the Baxter building or four
Freedom's Plaza right in Years Gone by
in Marvel Comics but the base of
operations in general for the Fantastic
Four has a kind of force field around it
it's why like the average tourist in the
city of New York can't just walk into
the Baxter building and start taking
pictures right because there's a force
field that they can't get through and
this is supposed to be impenetrable to
everybody except for the Fantastic Fork
who basically have a kind of access code
of sorts that allows them in and out but
the fact that Robert Reynolds could get
in here baffles read Because as far as
Read's concerned he's never met this guy
once in his life and even Robert
Reynolds has all the dressings of a
person who's struggling with mental
illness he talks about being a superhero
he has like his costume but in reality
it's a leather jacket with a cape that's
tied on with clothes pins I mean the guy
looks like he's struggling with mental
illness but through it all all he's
resolutely convinced that he knows who
Reid Richards is and so when Reed starts
asking like why should I remember you
like I don't know anything about you man
the response of Robert Reynolds is yes I
don't know how to make you understand
somehow everybody's been conditioned to
forget I ever existed you're supposed to
think I'm just some drunk who took a
wrong turn I don't know what happened I
think there may have been some kind of
conspiracy you see the mental illness
that could potentially be perpetuated
here right and so what he says the only
real thing he says here is he says I
want you to try and remember one thing
for me Reed you went to a wedding once I
want you to remember a wedding and the
response of read is why and that's when
Robert Reynolds says because something's
going to happen something Monumental and
when it does I'm going to need your help
and so where Reed initially kind of
dismisses him Robert Reynolds kind of
sniffs a rose and then just says unicorn
and that seems to be this triggering
word because while read Richard's up to
this point it's just kind of been like
like all right man you need to leave
suddenly it jogs a kind of sensation
within read where he says like like I
don't remember that I'm not allowed to
remember that and that's when Robert
Reynolds leaves and so what ends up
happening is Reed basically goes back
into the Baxter building he meets with
Susan storm and then says like did we
ever go to a to a wedding once right
where there was like a unicorn or
something like that and lo and behold as
they're having this conversation
seemingly this golden unicorn that's
literally sitting on the wall seems to
basically just appear now the reality
here is it's always been there it's just
for whatever reason Reid Richards and
none of the other members of the
Fantastic Four were allowed to remember
either the Unicorn or the events that
led to him being given the Unicorn so in
reality they just walked by it all the
time with no concept that it was even
there and so in response to this Reid
asked the question where did that come
from and so that's when Susan says read
I can't explain why but I get the
strangest feeling from this the oddest
sense of deja vu and that's when Reed
says I know me too it's the most curious
thing but I'll swear all of this has
happened once before so it's just this
really really amazing moment where it's
like Robert Reynolds is telling the
truth and and Reed Richards the
Fantastic Four they're all kind of
coming to this realization that this guy
is not lying but ultimately this you
know golden unicorn is sitting on top of
a tape and so when Reed Richards takes
the tape and then puts it into the VCR
that once he hits play the entirety of
the Fantastic Four are in a State of
Shock because on this VCR tape is read
Richards himself telling him you may
never ever see the contents of this tape
and if you don't the universe is better
off for it but if for some terrible
reason you are watching this tape then
it means a man named Robert Reynolds has
come to visit you and he's told you that
he's the century and is sending you on
this path to understand what's going on
but if Robert Reynolds is now back that
means the void is returning as well
that's his premonition and if the void
is truly here then we are all as good as
debt and so following that it literally
picks up with Robert Reynolds traveling
to go see the Incredible Hulk this is a
really really really cool moment here
because as you guys know the nature of
the Incredible Hulk Mythos is the hoax
just like a giant green rage monster who
always wants to be left alone and being
able to attain not only the Friendship
but the respect of the Hulk is a pretty
Monumental thing now one of the other
things that I want you to notice as well
that's going on with uh with with the
century is that his costume is actually
changing it's one of the small little
subtle things that takes place over the
course of the comic but his costume
actually evolves over the course of the
comic book and becomes really a true
costume for himself one of the things to
know and while it's not overly
Illustrated here in the comic is
established later on in his appearances
in Marvel but the century has the
ability to alter reality it's not on the
grand scale that you have with like
Franklin Richards or anybody like that
or at least we haven't really seen it on
that level the void can do that but
Robert Reynolds himself the century is
just a guy who can kind of alter reality
in like a localized space it's more used
as a plot device than anything else but
as soon as the Incredible Hulk realizes
that Robert Reynolds there he
immediately hugs him and recognizes him
as Golden man so for reasons that Robert
Reynolds himself isn't even fully aware
of the Incredible Hulk remembers who he
is and one of the funny things here is
that that Robert even kind of Muses to
himself and asking the question do you
remember me because you transformed back
and forth between the Incredible Hulk
and Bruce Banner and then that begs the
question just Bruce Banner remember who
I am when he's in his human form more so
than that the century right Robert
Reynolds refers to the Incredible Hulk
as Banner something he absolutely
despises but the reality here is that
because the relationship between the two
is so close the Incredible Hulk I
wouldn't argue is overly receptive to it
but actually gives into the idea this
kind of recognition that banner and Hulk
are basically the same person but more
so than that and what's really important
here is the century says he's going to
need the Hulk's help and when the Hulk
asks why the response to the century is
because the void's coming back and in a
very rare display in Marvel Comics The
Incredible Hulk shows fear he's
terrified of the Void right absolutely
afraid of this guy and that really is
just a testament to the power of the
Void literally the response of the Hulk
is the shadow man is coming back like I
don't want to have to deal with that and
so literally he says like when the when
the century says I'm I need you to be
brave Hawk I need you to be braver than
you've ever been the response of the
Hulk is always for Golden Man Hulk will
be bravest there is and it's just this
really really touching and kind of
emotional moment right where it's like
this really almost kind of scared
childlike sensitive side of what we
would otherwise normally see as just
being this rage monster that storms
throughout the world and can literally
obliterate virtually anything in his
path but the other part of this right
kind of jumping back to read Because
what you guys will notice is a lot of
the story kind of focuses on Reed
Richards to a degree as he's going
through and kind of figuring all these
little pieces out and so on that what he
does is he literally kind of goes
through his own journal and he says like
I'm now willing to admit the further I
go the more distant I feel as if
abstractly removed from the comfortable
evidence of civilization around me it's
as though I'm being drawn into a
Whirlpool ever decreasing concentrated
Circles of intrigue the facts Rush by in
front of me and I cannot reach out to
grasp them every time I try an
undercurrent of Truth tugs at my
awareness and pulls me deeper and so
what he's saying here is that all this
information is literally rushing by him
right he's looking up these files on
like Robert Reynolds according to the
files he's deceased he's dead he doesn't
exist anymore and so the question is if
this dead man is standing in front of
Reed and having a conversation with him
he's obviously not dead so why do Reed
Richard's own files show that he's dead
why is there a video of Reed Richards
telling him the end of the world is nigh
because Robert Reynolds is back and the
void is ultimately returning as well
it's this really really cool
conversation because he says I have only
one Theory which seems inapplicable upon
further scrutiny if Robert Reynolds was
placed in the federal witness protection
program he doesn't seem to remember it
and that doesn't follow the modus
operandi of the program himself now
again this seems fairly far-fetched and
it is and it's supposed to be because
what this shows is that a highly
scientific logical and intelligent mind
like Reed is grasping its straws for
what's going on with this whole
situation throwing out these far-flung
theories well maybe he's in the witness
protection program and that's why nobody
he remembers him because he's just
trying to understand what's going on
more so than that and he says there's
something else that really tugs at me
and bothers me that this is something
that I haven't experienced since I was a
little kid I basically am developing an
irrational fear of the dark and so what
it does is it jumps to Robert Reynolds
when he goes to visit Spider-Man and
this is a cool thing because he
literally says do you ever get the
feeling you're forgetting something
Peter right he knows that that Peter
Parker's Spider-Man but Peter Parker not
remembering Robert Reynolds plays the
role in saying well I don't know who
this Peter guy is but if I ever see him
you know then I'll pass on this this
message that you have but it's kind of
funny because Robert Reynolds is
recollecting on a life that he had when
he knew that Peter Parker was Spider-Man
and they knew each other and they teamed
up and they went on adventures to a guy
who doesn't know who he is right so for
Peter it's just kind of like Robert
Reynolds coming off as crazy I mean
Robert Reynolds is talking about this
like SNL skit where it was like they
were pretending to be the century and
Peter Parker on like a rooftop you know
all that kind of stuff and that's one of
the things to know is that Robert
Reynolds was seemingly at least when the
world was aware that he was a superhero
was the superhero he was the guy now of
course this story is written a few years
before Adam the legend of blue Marvel so
again you know Adam Brashear hasn't
really been introduced yet we don't
really know his origin story and in fact
we don't even know he exists at this
point in time in Marvel Comics but the
thing about it is that like in a lot of
ways Robert Reynolds was the guy that
taught superheroes how to be superheroes
he was a hero before the Fantastic Four
before Spider-Man before Doctor Strange
before any of those guys Rose to
prominence with their various powers and
capabilities and that in that time when
they were nursing at the teat of what it
meant to be a superhero Robert Reynolds
had long since been playing this role so
he was as much a mentor and a friend to
the superhero Community as anything else
and so that's where he literally says
like here's the thing Peter you got a
picture of me on a rooftop and I won you
a Pulitzer Prize because of that a
portrait of the century and when Peter's
just like like when he pulls out the
picture and shows it to Peter all Peter
sees is a blank piece of paper again his
mind's been altered to where he doesn't
know who the century is and so as the
conversation continues on unlike Reed
Richards where he's kind of like you
know I'm not supposed to remember that
because there's a keyword that's given
Peter Parker doesn't get that instead
all that happens is that Robert Reynolds
tells Peter as he swings away he says go
check magazines write Clarion Time Life
magazine and see why they're misnumbered
because magazines do not miss their
numbering it's one of the most
religiously important things about
magazines it always runs in sequence but
if you go and you look those magazines
up you'll find issues that are gone and
so ask yourself the question where did
they go to why don't they exist and so
what it does is it jumps back to read as
he literally goes into like this
basement right like this old filing
these old filing cabinets that he has
that he hasn't touched in years and as
he starts sorting through these things
he finds all these old news articles
right all these little newspaper
clippings about the century teaming up
with the Avengers and all this kinds of
stuff and in the middle of this whole
investigation Doctor Strange appears out
of nowhere and says yes this Century
does exist but he's exceedingly cryptic
because when Reed Richard starts asking
him questions like okay well tell me
what you know what's going on here the
response of Doctor Strange is I can't
give you any answers and the reason why
is because if I tell you the truth it'll
lead to the ruin of all because the
truth of this is that you're going to
trace that truth to its Genesis point to
where all of this started and when that
happens the universe will end because of
that and so the response to Doctor
Strange is I'm not going to give you
answers but what I will do is I will
give you a vision and so in this Vision
that he shows read what we get is a
conversation between the two where
Reed's just working on some kind of a
device right and says like I pray to God
it works we have to have precious little
time to pull this off and so right when
they activate this thing read Richard
makes a request of doctor strange and
when Dr Strange says what is it that you
want from me the responsive read is the
century if we ever remember him in the
name of all Humanity promise me you'll
do whatever you can to make us forget
and so ultimately Doctor Strange says
like I will not answer the question that
you originally asked me read but I will
propose to you another question can you
take your own advice you on the
videotape before I destroy the VCR right
you on the videotape told yourself you
have to stop following this path do not
follow this to its to its logical
conclusion if you do everything will end
that's you telling yourself that read
can you take your own advice and so
following that it switches over to the
X-Men and it has like Robert Reynolds
visiting Professor Xavier now Professor
Xavier is one of the most powerful
telepaths in existence in Marvel Comics
I mean this guy's telepathy at different
points in time has rivaled gods and so
when you have a situation like this
where whatever manipulation has been
done that's basically blocked all
knowledge of the Century's existence
from Xavier's mind it's got to be pretty
potent and so as this conversation
unfolds much like Reed Richards that
Xavier starts to remember kind of the
existence of the century he doesn't
remember the details he doesn't remember
everything that happens but he does kind
of remember him to a degree and that's
when literally the century tells him I'm
going to need your help the void is
coming back and when that happens like
when Xavier is told that much like what
we saw with the Incredible Hulk Xavier's
scared out of his wits he's terrified
and so what we end end up doing here is
we actually end up jumping over to the
superheroes of Europe now they're not
overly important here right I mean we
never see these guys again but what they
do is they contact their base of
operations specifically Gareth and
saying like we need help right like this
Force here is annihilating all of us
right like we're some of the most
capable superheroes throughout Europe
it's crushing us right it's literally
just steamrolling through us we need
backup we need reinforcements something
you have to send a before it comes back
but ultimately the communication's cut
now of course this was the void
attacking and that's one of the things
that I want to solidify here that while
Paul jingles and Jay Lee kind of play it
fast and loose with the nature of the
Void in terms of just how powerful it is
the most amazing example of the void's
power was in The Siege on Asgard one
shot what if comic right where like you
had the whole conflict in Asgard and so
on and so forth we don't have to go into
the details of it but in effect in that
story the void basically kills every
superhero on Earth and then spreads out
into the universe presumably killing
everything out there as well it's an
amazing display of just how powerful the
void is I mean it's on a whole different
level but following that we jump over to
Peter Parker of course at The Daily
Bugle he's visited by his uh his
Superior Robbie Robertson who's like why
are you here so late what are you doing
here like this early in the morning and
Peter took the advice of Robert Reynolds
and he's combing through all these
magazines Right Time Magazine Life
Magazine Clarion magazine Clarion
magazine being the magazine cover that
got Peter the Pulitzer Prize where he
had the image of the century on the
front and what he tells you know Robbie
Robertson is like these are misnumbered
there's issues missing here there's
magazines issues missing and no one
knows where they are they don't exist
here in the building they're not stored
digitally they don't exist anywhere and
that's when Robbie Robertson is like
there is no issue number 743 right
that's the one that had the century on
the cover he's like there is no issue
number 743 it doesn't exist it's not
allowed to so it's very creepy and very
weird in terms of like what's going on
but as Peter starts to look through
these magazines you do have issue number
743 of Clarion on but there's nothing on
the cover but his pursuit of this
information leads to him remembering the
century and him remembering the century
actually manifests in the form of the
cover becoming clear and then he sees
the image that the century was showing
him where he was posing for the cover of
the magazine that one Peter the Pulitzer
Prize and he says oh my God Robbie the
century I remember him I remember
everything and so that's when the
century goes to visit Tony Stark now
unlike everybody else Tony Stark
remembers exactly who Robert Reynolds is
he remembers Robert Reynolds down to a T
and it's one of those things where he
does isn't necessarily an enemy of
Robert but he's not really a friend and
he's just kind of like I mean like it's
this is you know I haven't seen you in a
long time where have you been man like
what's been going on and so one of the
things that I want to point out is that
it's interesting how this is done
because Tony Stark does not remember
elements of Robert Reynolds he remembers
the general idea of the century but he
doesn't really remember everything else
now one of the interesting things here
about Iron Man is that he remembers
Robert Reynolds as a person he doesn't
really seem to remember this Century at
all or at least that aspect of him
instead like as he meets Robert and as
Robert starts asking him like I really
starts saying like I remember Tony Stark
I remember everything why of all people
why did you turn against me why do the
superheroes of Earth turn against me why
did everybody literally just wipe my
existence from the minds of everyone now
one of the things that I want to want to
remind you guys of Robert Reynolds is
only piecing things together here he
doesn't have all the details he doesn't
have all the files but the reality is
that Tony Stark's response much like
everybody else is I don't necessarily
recall everything but in terms of of
Robert Reynolds own recollection of the
events that he's talking about here it's
really Iron Man that kind of spills the
beans to a degree and saying like I
don't remember all the details right
like for the the event that you're
talking about here Robert of being
betrayed by the superheroes I don't
remember all the details all I remember
is that something really bad seemed to
have happened and the superheroes were
all called together and you were called
to us and that I stood by you and said
no this is Robert Reynolds how could
like this Revelation possibly be true
but this revelation of him the things
he's done how could any of it be true
this guy saved Our Lives more times than
you could possibly imagine but the
determination right the verdict of the
superheroes on Earth The Avengers
specifically is at the end of the day he
is a superhero he's done some great
things but for the benefit of all
existence Robert Reynolds has to die he
has to go away and so when this bit of a
revelation comes out that Robert
Reynolds really almost kind of befriends
Tony Starkey sort of calms down and then
he tells him like the void's coming back
I'm going to need your help and of
course Tony Stark recalls who the void
is and what the void's capable of and
that's when the only thing he actually
utters here is God save us all right
like may God help us all and so as the
the century continues on his journey he
ends up basically realizing what he's
not supposed to remember or at least
another bit of a recollection comes to
him in the form of being able to
actually see the century Watchtower and
so when he gets there he discovers
what's basically a condescending Cynthia
computer which is called clock and so of
course with this being a Cindy and
computer the most logical thing to do is
to ask it questions that can reveal
information because for the most part
computers aren't really biased but of
course they store a ton of information
and so the first and logical question
that Robert Reynolds asks is do you know
where I've been but the response that
clock offers here is I cannot give you
an answer to that question there's a
virus that's been planted deep inside of
me that prevents me from being able to
give you an answer to that question and
I guess you could override me but I've
been told to tell you that you shouldn't
and so there's a kind of device that
hovers out there really in front of
clock and the questions asked like is
this some kind of like a cloaking
mechanism or something like that and the
responsive clock is no the device you're
looking at is a transmitter I detect the
emission of a subliminal message it is
carried on a most powerful signal
capable of reaching across our planet
and far outside its atmosphere the
device appears to be powered by your own
serum and so when the century asked do
you know why it's here the response of
clock is I am forbidden to answer that
question so the reality here is that
this device that Robert riddles is
studying this is the device that's
sending a signal out into the world
making everybody forget of the Century's
existence this is the reason why nobody
remembers because this device is being
emitted with such a level of power that
even high level telepaths like Charles
Xavier are unable to overcome the
influence of the signal itself and so of
course following this Robert riddle says
then disable the transmitter but that's
when clock says I'm unable to comply and
when Robert asks by who he says by your
order sir he says I must urge caution I
am obliged to inform you that the virus
will disable my operating systems
rendering me unsalvageable if you
attempt to tamper with the transmitter
so it's one of these things where it's
like if you mess with this you'll
ultimately end up destroying me and
whatever purpose this transmitter serves
will now be Moot and so he asks a
follow-up question do you remember the
last time you saw me and of course clock
says yes and then he says who is present
and he says you were sir and he says can
you access the last order given to you
before the device was activated and the
responsive clock is I am forbidden I am
forbidden to do it and then of course
Sentry asks it doesn't matter I don't
need the order I just need to know who
gave you the order and the response of
clock is it was given by Reed Richards
so it's this really really cool moment
because given what little information
he's been able to piece together the
perception of Robert Reynolds is that
this device that emits a transmitter
that blocks the world from remembering
his existence was established there by
Reed Richards and that Reed Richards
himself had told clock ensure that
Robert Reynolds does not mess with this
transmitter should he ever show up by
all standards of measurement it appears
that Reed Richards is an enemy of Robert
Reynolds but at the end of the day for
the century it doesn't really matter he
ends up dismantling the device in the
first place and that's when he starts to
realize it's a curious thing this thing
seems to have been put together in a
hurry there's no trip wires there's no
additional viruses but there's nothing
going on that even seemingly messing
with the transmitter and the idea that
it would destroy clock was a lie but he
was designed to kind of keep him away
but as soon as the device is deactivated
the world immediately remembers who
Robert Reynolds is they immediately
recall everything about it people who
had posters of the century all over
their room remember now that the posters
were there even like Billy Turner who
was actually the sidekick of the century
right his name was Scout he recalls that
like he was the sidekick of the century
Reed Richards remembers everything going
on with like the wedding and the whole
nine yards everybody recalls his
existence but what's so interesting
about all this and what's so intriguing
about all this is nobody recalls why the
device was created in the first place
nobody seems to remember that but the
important thing here is that the century
sees Reed Richards as his enemy more so
than that Billy Turner Scout actually
ends up donning his costume even with
one arm missing and just these massive
scars on his body and then shows up to
join the century now one of the things
that's not necessarily directly covered
here but is a really interesting aspect
of their history is that Scout was
actually brutally attacked by the void
that's why he looks the way he does
that's why he's missing an arm because
he was attacked in such an extreme way
and so it's a really interesting thing
because when Robert Reynolds gets back
to his house of course his dog Watchdog
remembers who he is and then Lindy's
there now remember in the last video
that we did Lindy left him because she
didn't remember that Robert Reynolds was
a century and is far she was concerned
he had succumbed to alcoholism again
right he's drinking from like his
special bottle he's babbling on about
how he has powers all the signs of a guy
who has schizophrenia and coping with
alcoholism and she believed he had been
and you know managed to put the alcohol
behind him he was seeing a therapist
different things like that so believing
her husband had kind of relapsed into
his old ways she left but once she
basically remembers everything she comes
running back because it's one of those
things where it's like I'm so sorry like
I I I didn't know like I didn't know any
of this stuff now of course Robert
Reynolds is quick to forgive because the
reality is that it isn't her fault her
mind had been tampered with and screwed
with but in the midst of this
conversation in this kind of reunion
between himself and Lindy the void
attacks and that's one of the craziest
things is because the void immediately
overpowers the century so right off the
bat one of the first things that were
that's really established here is the
void is more powerful than the century
is but then he even kind of taunts him
right he says Step Closer Golden Boy
decide if you truly value your female's
life the darkness has yet to fall
perhaps I am not yet strong enough to
snap her spine like a dry twig but can
you afford to take that chance and so
where the century seems to maybe kind of
make a move or so he's attacked and
incapacitated by the void who simply
says just as I thought ever the same
Century a little hero child with a heart
of wax I told you I'd come back Robert
as you always knew deep inside your soul
I would return and so what Robert
Reynolds asked like what is it that you
want the response to the void is the
same thing I always wanted to eradicate
everything to destroy all life in this
universe to feed on everything this
universe has to offer and then leave and
travel to the next one and so ultimately
the void ends up taking off but in that
Revelation and with everybody
remembering the century the century
himself responds and kind of like
broadcasts nationally to the world and
saying all these weird freak accidents
that you've been reading about right
these storms in London or these these
things that have been going on right
these major calamities that didn't
really seem to have any scientific
explanation that this is all the actions
of the Void you know who I am and you
know how powerful the void is that if I
return turn the void's return the void
in turn will lay waste to all and so
what I am asking for is this I am asking
for all of you to stay as calm as
possible I'm asking for the superheroes
to Rally to my side I know you're scared
and I know you're terrified of how
powerful the void is truth to tell he
could potentially eradicate all of us
but we have to stand together if there's
any chance for us to succeed so meet me
at the Statue of Liberty and together
all of us superheroes and super villains
alike will stand against the power of
the void and so what's really awesome
about this is that they respond
initially of course the Incredible Hulk
shows up right off the bat and there's
even this uncertainty as to whether
anybody else will appear but they do
Spider-Man Captain America even Billy
Turner Scout shows up right The Avengers
the X-Men the Fantastic Four there's
even villains here like Dr Octopus and
of course there's other villains outside
of him as well but Dr Octopus says like
even those of us in the villain
Community understand the level of threat
that's posed here by the existence of
the Void he will kill us all he will
destroy every single one of us and so
when Reed Richards Show shows up there's
a very tense moment between Robert
Reynolds and Reed where based on the
memories of things that Robert Reynolds
recalls Reed basically turned against
him right read like lied like even
during the funeral of Robert Reynolds
when he had quote unquote died that Rita
told the world that he was a traitor
that by all standards of measurement
Reed had betrayed the Friendship of
Robert Reynolds and then destroyed his
memory in order for you know for
whatever reason that made sense to read
even Reynolds himself doesn't fully
understand but the reality is that the
events that are unfolding here and the
arrival of the Void are way more
important than anything else and so what
ends up going on is of course as the
void basically makes his appearance here
that Robert Reynolds is the first one to
step up and the first one to launch an
attack and it's like this amazing moment
here because you have these Heroes who
do want to attack as best they can but
for the most part they're scared right
they're terrified out of their wits
people like Thor step up Thor gets
crushed but then that's when like Doctor
Strange appears to read that quite
literally Doctor Strange slows down time
and then says we need to have a
conversation you now know that you are
the the one who created the device that
blocked the Century's memories or the
existence of the century from everybody
in the world and you're the one who
spoke at his funeral talking of him
being a traitor but do you know why you
did all of this do you know why any of
this happened in the first place and
this is one of the best moments of the
entirety of the story that what ends up
happening is the Fantastic Four arrive
in New York and the entirety of the
place is just crushed devastated right
like millions and millions of people
have been killed here and that Robert
Reynolds himself is facing off against
the void but that in this fight the
Fantastic Four came to a realization
that the void is not just some arbitrary
enemy out there that the void is the
century they're they're two sides of the
same coin and that's the reason why all
of this is happening that the reality
and the reason why the device was
created in the first place Robert
Reynolds has partial memories Reed is
now remembering all of it that with this
Revelation that Robert Reynolds is the
void and the void is Robert Reynolds the
void is the physical manifestation of
every fear and every anxiety and every
dark desire that Robert Reynolds has
right everything that makes him or at
least the the darker side of him
manifests in the form of the void and
the void his power is Limitless there's
nothing the void can't do and so faced
with this Revelation that's when the
century is called before the Avengers
and the Fantastic Four and they bring to
his attention the fact that they now
know it was The Dark Secret of the
century it's what he kept from everybody
he hid it from every single person
nobody knew the truth but now that the
truth is out their response is in order
for the world to be saved in order for
the world to be safe from the effects of
the Void the century has to die and
ultimately what ended up happening is
that faced with the prospect of his own
demise the idea of the century just
literally being killed by whatever
Manner and whatever means that himself
and and Reed Richards just got drunk
right they just spent the whole time
drinking and that's when it dawned on
read there's an alternative to this
right if the void exists because the
century exists then why not just make it
so that so nobody remembers the century
if you yourself don't remember that
you're the Century the century can't
manifest and if it can't manifest the
void can't manifest right because the
void draws its power partially from the
Sentry and so this idea is kind of
cooked up to create the device that
would allow everybody to forget the
century exists right to wipe their minds
but it wasn't enough to kind of wipe
their minds of the century because
ultimately people would come looking
right somebody somewhere might remember
something and then as that time
progresses they'll start to recollect
this great superhero that the world has
seemingly forgotten and so in order to
push the world in a direction to where
they not only forget the century but
have no desire to go looking for him the
story was concocted that the century was
actually a traitor that the century was
a villain he was a bad guy that
everything you thought you knew about
him wasn't a lie that he was not a
superhero of the people and this turned
Society against Robert Reynolds and so
that's why it was so easy for the world
to forget and so in the revelation of
this and the recollection of this
absolute truth that's when Reed comes to
the realization and even Robert Reynolds
himself gaining all this truth even in
just like talking to Reed comes to the
realization the only way for the void to
be defeated is for the century to
basically be forgotten again it's the
only way to make that work the void's
just too powerful he can't be defeated
by any of the superheroes on earth now
of course people may end up asking the
question why don't they just get the
Infinity Gauntlet different things like
that the reality here is asking that
kind of question actually takes away
from what makes this story so phenomenal
because it's not a it's not a simple
comic book story where it's like well
let's just grab The Infinity Gauntlet or
like a Cosmic Cube and we'll just will
the center or the void out of existence
and like the days safe it's too you know
that's that's a traditional comic book
story what made this so cool is that it
removed all those things and it focused
on the the human elements of the
characters more so than that as Reed
Richard starts to spill these beams and
really kind of bring this Revelation to
Robert Reynolds that what he says is
like when we activated the device and
when I made the video for myself telling
me if you ever see this tape the whole
world is screwed you were there Robert
Reynolds you were there when it happened
you were part of all of this you and I
worked together to create this device to
install the virus even when I told
Doctor Strange if the time ever comes
when I remember or anybody else
remembers the century you have to do
everything you can to make us forget you
were standing like right over there and
listening to what I was saying and you
agreed with it all and that's when the
void comes to the realization that the
century is remembering everything and so
the void goes on this extreme attack in
order to not only destroy the century
but seemingly everybody else but at the
end of the day you literally have the
century and the Fantastic Four doctor
strange and so on who raced to the
century Watchtower as fast as they
possibly can and then reactivate the
device and it's a very crushing moment
because for a moment here Robert
Reynolds was able to entertain the idea
that he might be able to come back that
he might be able to be a superhero again
that he can go back to the life that he
had and could potentially defeat the
void but the truth about this is that it
can't be that way that you can't have
the century without having the void and
because the void is this Unstoppable
force of nature the only way to save the
world from the void is to wipe away
existence of the century Robert Reynolds
has to destroy everything that makes him
who he is even his own identity in order
to save the world and at the end of the
day they do it they activate the device
and everything shuts down everybody
forgets that Robert Reynolds is the
century yet again that the void vanishes
he's gone disappeared and even like when
Robert Reynolds is in the car with Lindy
herself they're surveying all this
damage right like they're literally just
driving to go get some food somewhere
they're surveying all this damage in New
York which not even that long ago like a
couple days before was because the void
was there and like the Sentry was there
and all that kind of stuff and Robert
Reynolds was there but because of the
device nobody knows why all this
happened it's considered like a freak
storm that's basically it it's
incredibly well written and it's
incredibly well done because you do get
this kind of brief little moment here
where you have Robert Reynolds and you
have Lindy who go to a restaurant in
order to get some food right they go to
Burger Palace which is where Billy
Turner Works scout who's still missing
an arm and still has all these scars and
Robert Reynolds kind of looks at him and
to a degree almost feels this level of
repulse but even on a basic level while
we're not really told it's almost like
he kind of remembers who Billy Turner is
that he remembers who Scout is and he
remembers why all this is being done in
the first place and so unlike in the
previous instance when he himself was
made to forget the truth about this is
he seems to choose to forget now we're
not explicitly told this and this is
more of a theory than anything else
right like by all standards a
measurement he doesn't recall anything
but the fact that he just kind of smirks
to himself when he sees Billy Turner
after this kind of like Envision right
like Burger Palace big chili hot dogs
big chili dogs big enough to satisfy
even a hero's hunger he remembers right
he remembers this stuff and so he kind
of smiles to himself and then just
orders a chili dog and that's where the
story ends but this is one of the
greatest comic book stories ever in the
history of Marvel Comics let me know
what you guys think down in the comments
section thank you all for watching and I
will catch you on later peace